kämpferische worte von wladimir selensky
in einer neuen ansprache spricht der
ukrainische präsident seinem volk mut zu
und macht den menschen gleichzeitig
hoffnung es wird eine zeit nach dem
krieg geben
in seiner rede die er in den sozialen
medien postete oyster zur lenski
außerdem seine dankbarkeit für die
entscheidungen von us präsident biden
und dem britischen premier boris johnson
öl importe aus russland zu verbieten und
warnt dass alles geld das noch an die
russische regierung fließt für den krieg
genutzt wird
liebe ukraine heute gibt es wichtige
nachrichten die vereinigten staaten
haben einen schritt unternommen der die
russischen besatzer erheblich schwächen
er wird sie für die aggression und all
das böse was sie getan haben bezahlen
lassen amerika verbietet die einfuhr von
erdölprodukten gas und kohle aus
russland außerdem dürfen us-bürger nicht
mehr in den russischen brennstoff und
energiesektor investieren ich bin dem
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten joe
biden sehr dankbar für diese
entscheidung für diese führung für
dieses signal an die ganze welt es ist
ganz einfach jeder cent der in russland
geht wird zur kurve oder granate die in
souveräne staaten einschlägt
von der europäischen union erwarten wir
harte entscheidungen und sanktionen
gegen russland für diesen krieg für
diese aggression und das werden die
verantwortlichen noch bereuen es wird
notwendig deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
die russische führung erkennt die
vereinigten staaten
britannien die europäische union kanada
australien japan und andere freie länder
der welt werden folgen lassen sie sich
also nicht täuscht sanktionen können
nicht umgangen werden der krieg muss
enden wir müssen uns an den
verhandlungstisch setzen aber ehrlich
sachlich im interesse